So, it's been a tough couple
of weeks
for right-wing
conspiracy theorist
and overly-microwaved
baked potato Alex Jones.
-He...
-(laughter)
Aah! Looks pretty done.
Put it in there
for another three minutes!
(laughter)
The pioneer of "Pizzagate,"
who spent decades
spreading outlandish stories,
like Lady Gaga being a demon,
and tap water turning kids gay,
is embroiled
in a very public custody battle.
Hey, guys, he just wants his...
♪ Baby back, baby back,
baby back ♪
♪ He wants his baby back,
baby back, baby back. ♪
Jones' ex-wife claims he is,
"not a stable person."
What the (bleep)?!
This guy not stable?
You're in the cult, bro!
You're the threat to America!
You are who we're at war with,
you traitorous little rat.
Sustained! Take those kids.
(laughter)
They'll be fine.
Jones' legal team is trying
to justify his unhinged rants
by claiming he is just
a performance artist
playing a character.
And his lawyer actually said,
"Like Jack Nicholson
as the Joker in Batman."
-(laughter)
-Same (bleep) thing.
-But that's not the Infowars
kingpin's only
specious legal argument.
In a deposition, Alex Jones
admitted he smokes marijuana,
but, quote, right here,
"to monitor its strength, which
is how law enforcement does it."
(laughter)
Which is why
Snoop Dogg was deputized.
-(laughter) -He's just testing
it all out for the rest of you.
What a public service.
Comedians, what's another
bull(bleep) legal defense
you might hear from Alex Jones?
-Timothy Simons.
-Uh, Your Honor,
I only put those cameras
in the bathroom
to find out who was flushing
the baby wipes.
They are really messing
with our pipes.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
All right, points. Yeah.
(applause)
-Mary.
-Your Honor,
you saw
how fuzzy those bunnies are.
How can I be blamed
for petting them so hard
-their spines snapped?
-HARDWICK: Yeah, points.
-It's not your fault. Matt.
-(laughter, applause)
Your Honor, I was only manning
that truck stop glory hole
to count how many perverts
are in El Paso.
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-(laughter)